In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadion for June 14, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Mithodios, the confessor, archbishop of Constantinople.
Our Holy Father Mithodios was of a wealthy family from Syracuse in Sicily.
When he had grown up, he went to Constantinople with the intention of following a glorious
career, but he encountered an old ascetic who suggested to him that it was more advantageous
to seek unending glory by taking up his cross to follow Christ.
The heart of the generous man was inflamed with spiritual zeal, and he decided to enter
the monastery of Canolacos in Bithinia, where he was much appreciated for his obedience in
every trial, as well as for his skills as a calligrapher.
During the reign of Michael I, 8-11-813, he was included among the clergy of the Holy
Patriarch Nikephorus, and became an archdeacon, and was later named Abid of his monastery.
He governed his community in peace until Emperor Leo let loose a new persecution against
Holy icons in 815.
When Patriarch Nikephorus was deposed and the confessors had been exiled or had sought refuge
in deserts and underground dens, St. Mithodios left for Rome not to spare his life, but to
prepare there a defense of the true faith in 817.
He was in close communication with the Pope, and obtained the promise that the Pope would
refuse to receive the sonotal letter sent by the heretical Patriarch Theldotus to obtain
the recognition of his enthronement.
When Michael II seized power in 820, Mithodios returned to Constantinople carrying a letter
from Pope Pascal I, outlining the solid arguments for the veneration of the Holy Images, and interceding
with the sovereign for the liberation of St. Nikephorus, but the Emperor paid no heed to
this document.
He accused Mithodios of stirring up a revolt, and ordered that he be given 700 lashes and
thrown into a narrow tomb-like dungeon on St. Andrews Island near Cape Acritas in the
company of two criminals.
One of them died after a year, and St. Mithodios was forced to bear this stench of his decomposing
corpse.
The dungeon possessed only a small window through which just enough bread and water to sustain
life was passed.
He was later transferred to Antigonese Island in the Princess Islands, where he managed to
carry on a correspondence with the other confessors, St. Michael, the Sincelos, and the
Graptus brothers.
These last wrote some verses in which they praised him as a dead man who was alive, who endured
for the truth, a living death.
He had been incarcerated for about nine years in 839, when Emperor Thelfilos came up against
a difficult passage in the Holy Scriptures, which his theologians could not resolve.
On the advice of one of his courtiers, he made contact with Mithodios.
The saint resolved the difficulty with ease, and Thelfilos called him back to Constantinople,
confining him in an ancient church near the palace.
One counselor alone had access to him in order to ask him about all sorts of questions that
remained insoluble to the Emperor's mind, which was avid for knowledge.
Thelfilos took him with him when he moved about, and on his military campaigns so that
he could enjoy his councils, but also because in spite of the precautions that had been taken
to keep him hidden, the saint was exercising a growing influence, both on the people and
at court, where he had been able to win over some of the highly placed officials to orthodoxy.
It was only on the death of the Sovereign in 842 that he was freed, on the order of the
Empress Regent Saint Theodora, along with all the other confessors.
He went to the monastery of Elegmi in Bethinia, which he had founded, and took up his ascetic
life once more.
One lent of that year he copied seven salters, one each week, in a magnificent script, and
eight and drank nothing except on Saturdays and Sundays.
The sufferings of the incarceration and exile had caused him to lose all his hair, and his
body was more like a corpse than that of a living being, keeping his jaw which had been broken
by the persecutors in place by binding two white Kirchiffs round his head, and despite
his mutilated lips, he assiduously preached the true faith, which he called the mother
of the virtues, unremittingly exhorting his hearers to the restoring of conduct that conformed
to the gospel, and to the canonical order that had been neglected during the persecution.
In March of 843, a council convoked by Empress Theodora, recognized the second council of
Nicaea, deposed the heretical patriarch John Gramaticus, and elected Saint Methodius in
his place, in conformity with the prediction of Saint Johnius, the Great.
As soon as he was enthroned, Methodius had Saint Thelfanis Graptus consecrated as Metropolitan
of Nicaea, and he received the support of Saint Simeon of Lesbos, and the other confessors
in the administration of the Patriarchate.
In those days, Saint Johnius and other confessors went to Constantinople, inspired by a divine
revelation, and persuaded the Patriarch and the Empress officially to restore the veneration
of the Holy icons.
At Theodora's request, all the champions of the Orthodox faith, Saint Johnius, Arsacius,
Naucratius, and the disciples of Saint Theodora, the Studeit.
Theodora and Thelfanis Graptus, Michael the Sinceles, gathered around Saint Methodius on the Friday
of the first week of Lent, to celebrate a vigil in Saint Sophia's for the forgiveness
of the soul of Thelfilus, who, according to his wife, had repented on his deathbed.
God showed that he had accepted their prayer, and a great procession was organized on Sunday
11 March in 843 to celebrate the restoration of the veneration of the Holy icons and the
triumph of Orthodoxy over all the heresies.
It was then decided that this event should be celebrated each year on the first Sunday
of the Great Fast, the Sunday of Orthodoxy.
Peace, however, was not thereby assured in the church.
Methodius, who had vowed not to give sleep to his eyes until the Orthodox faith reigned
everywhere, had still to battle against various heresies which had been introduced under cover
of iconoclasm.
Above all, he had to confront the painful divisions among the Orthodox themselves.
He led this action with the vigorous support of Saint Dionysius, who, just as Saint Antony,
in former times, had left his solitude to help Saint Athanasius, left Mount Olympus for
Constantinople.
The deposed patriarch John Grammatikos urged a woman to accuse Methodius of having raped
her.
The affair came to trial, but the saint confounded his accusers by uncovering his nakedness before
the tribunal and showing that a body so mortified and withered could hardly be thought to be animated
by any carnal desire.
He also revealed that, having been assailed by a violent temptation while in Rome, he
had obtained from Saint Peter the grace of chastity.
In conformity with the decisions of the synod, the holy patriarch deposed the bishops and
abbots who had compromised with the iconoclasts, but he showed an indulgent attitude towards
the lesser clergy forbidding that any cleric should be submitted to corporal punishment.
He had to fill the vacancies quickly, and the ordination of some of the clerics he chose
provoked opposition among the Orthodox clergy.
In particular, the monks of the studio rose up violently against the prelate, opposed
as they were to his climate measures, and also because he had not accorded them the place
they reckoned was theirs by reason of their battles for the defense of Orthodoxy.
In spite of the triumphal translation of the relics of Saint Theodore the Studeit
on the 26th of January in 844, at which the patriarch presided, this opposition was transformed
into open revolt when Methodius asked them to destroy the writings of Saint Theodore the
Studeit, directed against his predecessors, Theratius and Niqueferos, so that he finally ended
by declaring unanathema on all the monks of the studio.
A short time later, when the church was in the grip of this new schism, he went to see Saint
Ronissius, whose approaching death had been revealed to him.
This great ascetic exhorted all those who were present to peace and unity around their
patriarch, then fell asleep, saying that Methodius would join him eight months later.
In fact, the Holy Prelate did indeed become ill with a painful dropsy.
He attributed this illness to the excessive severity of his condemnation of the Studeits and
revoked his sentence, imposing penances on only the most recalcitrant among them.
He then fell asleep in peace on the 14th of June in 847, and was buried with great honor
in the Church of the Holy Apostles, in the Presence of all the people, through the prayers of
our Holy Father, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, of mercy on us, and save us.